dereck wrote in saying david do you have
an unpopular opinion that you hide from
others friends family whatever when it
comes to politics or news you know I
don't make it a secret that there are
some areas in which I don't completely
agree with the so-called left in the
United States these issues relate to for
example I don't believe that women make
77 cents on the dollar compared to men
in the United States we've we've looked
at that the number is more like 90
that is something that I know in certain
circles if I were to say it would cause
tension so it's not that I I did from
others but I might just choose not to
bring that up and say hey let's talk
about my views about the gender pay gap
right I wouldn't I wouldn't broach that
issue unnecessarily or something like
that my critiques of the some of the
protests for example to pick something
recent to the election of Donald Trump
in the women's March I've said some
aspects of it I found to be less than
productive and not a good good path
forward critiques of identity politics
for example realistic and sober rather
than sort of unhinged and distorted
understandings of the role of Islam in
world terrorism these are issues where I
don't know that I'd say it's unpopular
in general but among some of the people
that I'm around in my day-to-day life
they're probably not the most popular
views and I don't know that I'm hiding
them but I probably just choose not to
go into those issues I don't hold this
position anymore but when I was younger
I had more of a libertarian streak mmm
so I usually I used to have this idea
that private businesses should be able
to discriminate and basically you know
on the basis of like whatever basis of
race or gender not not out of any you
know bigotry on my end but just this
idea that this is their business they
can do what they want okay and that I
would be you know the first to boycott
and to protest that business but that
they should have the right they should
have the right yeah I mean my political
philosophy has just changed over time
because now I see we live in a society
that business has workers that were
educated in public schools uses roads
that everyone paid for everyone's tax
dollar supports their business no no of
course you can't discriminate but that
was an unpopular position I held at one
point not to mention the other the other
way to push and not that you believe
this anymore but just because it came to
mind you can also make the case that if
it is okay to have any regulation of
businesses right so for example when it
comes to the health insurance industry
if you believe that it's okay for the
government to say your health insurance
company you're for profit but if you
want to participate in this industry
there are certain rules that you have to
abide by if conceptually you're okay
with that then it has to conceptually be
okay for the government to say hey you
run your business as long as it's not
breaking any laws in terms of the
product or service that's all well and
good but we do have statutes which
identify certain classifications of
people the basis of which can't serve to
to reject service to members of those
classes that's completely consistent
with still believing in private business
as a concept you know what I mean oh
yeah absolutely and I mean there's this
plenty of people who think that the free
market can take care of it maybe maybe
it can in some instances but when it
comes to people's health when it comes
to people's education they shouldn't be
in charge of that I would say also an
unpopular opinion that I have is that I
think that deflategate was no big deal
and I don't engine that when I'm around
people who hate the New England Patriots
I support the New England Patriots I
think that is a an unpopular position
probably amongst their audience and
certainly nationwide yeah every time we
talk about it you should see the the
email that I get